d'abord la première chose c'est que pour
nous cette matinée et le début d'un long
retour sur le terrain des idées de la
réflexion et des propositions
vous le savez et il était plus que temps
notre famille politique ne peut pas se
contenter de s'opposer
elle a toujours le devoir de mettre sur
la table et de s'astreindre à faire cet
effort les propositions que nous nous
avançons
parce que et on doit en avoir
profondément conscience quand les
français nous regarde
l'interrogation qu'il se pose toujours
c'est eux si nous leur faisons confiance
que feront thiais et le regard qu'ils
portent sur les républicains n'est pas
le même regard que celui qui est porté
sur la france insoumis sur le front
national sur les extrêmes parce que ce
qu'ils attendent de nous c'est d'être
capable d'être ensuite aux
responsabilités de ne pas se contenter
de dire mais de faire il est donc
fondamental et je remercie
virginie guilhaume luc ferry de
l'investissement qu'ils ont accepté de
faire pour reconstruire dans le cadre de
cette reconstruction totale d'une
nouvelle droite
nos idées soient quoi nous croyons les
valeurs que nous portons
pourquoi est ce que nous avons souhaité
commencer par ce sujet sur l'immigration
est tout simplement parce que c'est sans
doute une des priorités principales pour
l'avenir de notre pays
comment ne pas voir les difficultés
massive de l'intégration aujourd'hui
comment ne pas voir la montée régulière
dans nos villes dans nos territoires de
la pression de l'intégrisme et du
communautarisme
comment ne pas mesurer petit à petit les
reculs incessant de la république face
aux revendications portées notamment par
l'islam intégriste
le nombre de mosquées salafistes plus de
sens là où on en a à peine fermé 3 la
multiplication du port du voile
la diffusion progressive d'un discours
de haine de la france et ces images qui
nous ont tous choqués au lendemain de
l'assassinât du colonel beltrame
ou à l'intérieur même du quartier ozanam
au fond on sentait très bien que ici ça
n'était plus la république ça n'était
plus la france est que les gens soient
détenteurs de l'autorité républicaine
journalistes ou élus d'autres avaient
pris la place de ce qu'était la
république nous pouvons prendre ces
sujets par tous les bouts mais il ya une
réalité qui s'impose
et cette réalité c'est celle du nombre
et les mathématiques ont la tête dure
quand depuis autant d'années
depuis aussi longtemps nous avons de
façon aussi déraisonnable dépasser
toutes les capacités d'intégration de
notre pays en laissant rentrer en france
beaucoup plus d'immigrés que ce que nous
étions capables d'accueillir nous avons
nous mêmes créé les problèmes auxquels
nous nous heurtons aujourd'hui ni plus
ni mois ils rentrent chaque année trop
d'immigrés en france c'est cette réalité
à laquelle nous nous heurtons les
chiffres de ce point de vue sont
consternants 2010 cette première année
des manuels macron 262000 titre de
séjour c'est un record jamais depuis
plus de 40 ans la france n'a accepté
qu'il y ait autant d'étrangers qui
rentre sur son sol jamais depuis 40 ans
à l'époque c'était les trente glorieuses
une situation de croissance économique
une capacité à intégrer qui était plus
facile aujourd'hui nous avons le taux de
chômage que nous connaissons
particulièrement douloureux pour les
jeunes nous nous heurtons à des blocages
culturels pour intégrer ceux qui
viennent chez nous nous nous heurtons à
l'intégrisme religieux
jamais nous n'avons eu autant besoin de
diminuer l'immigration jamais nous
n'avons autant ouvert nos portes
c'est une folie et cette folie ne peut
conduire qu'à de grands désordres pour
notre pays de ce point de vue il faut
bien se dire les chiffres parce que le
débat sur l'immigration en france est
marquée du sceau de l'irrationnel
si rien n'est fait et si la tendance
n'est pas inversée le quinquennat
d'emmanuel macron se traduira par un
on d'immigrés en plus au bout de cinq
ans un million d'immigrés en plus et
encore je prends les chiffres qui sont
les plus optimistes
de ce point de vue la part des immigrés
dans la population française est déjà un
plus haut niveau qu'elle n'ait jamais
connue alors que propose le président de
la république
d'abord il ya quelque chose qui est tout
à fait ahurissant parfois dans ce déluge
de mots avec lesquels il cherche à
camoufler les faits il n'a jamais dit
qu'il fallait réduire l'immigration
jamais pendant la campagne
présidentielle il a clairement expliqué
que l'immigration était une chance pour
la france
tout le monde se souvient de la façon
dont il a alimenté le discours de
culpabilisation de la france notamment
par rapport à nous tirer le projet de
loi qui est autour de la table et il
remercie
eric guillaume pierre henry fabien tous
les amis mansour tous ceux qui en ce
moment porte notre voix à l'assemblée
nationale françois noël qui le fera
bientôt également au sénat l'an très
clairement montré ce projet de loi une
fois qu'on a laissé de côté tous les
galimatias qui consiste à faire semblant
ne contient aucune mesure sérieuse qui
vont permettre de réguler cette
explosion de l'immigration en france
parce qu'il ya bien une explosion c'est
plus 50% en 10 ans un seul exemple le
regroupement familial qu'il faudrait
réduire drastiquement va être encore
renforcés comme vous l'avez montré avec
la possibilité pour des mineurs
demandeurs d'asile non seulement de
faire venir les parents mais de faire
venir aussi tous les frères et ça il je
passe sur l'affaiblissement de la notion
de pays sûrs qu'ils vont être encore
diminué et anil après bien relevé ce
matin on voit en plus que dans les
débats
la véritable nature de ce qui est la
majorité de ce qui est en marche
transparaît il n'ya dans leurs
interventions à aucun moment la volonté
d'un discours qui soit ferme et qui soit
claire sur cette question
de l'immigration c'est révélateur et
c'est révélateur d'un débat interdit qui
est d'ailleurs étonnant parce que la
france parle souvent de ces questions
d'immigration depuis longtemps mais si
on compare notre débat avec le débat en
allemagne avec le débat au royaume uni
le débat chez nous est frappé du sceau
de l'irrationalité on ne met jamais les
chiffres sur la table on ne regarde
jamais la réalité en face
on cache les statistiques qui sont les
statistiques de l'immigration on ne
regarde pas ce qui se passe on n'en
débat pas en confrontant les points de
vue regardez la façon dont le débat se
passe en ce moment dans l'hémicycle ou
immédiatement des canots députés font
des propositions on leur pose avec ce
vieux réflexe pavlovien que nous
connaissons vous n'êtes pas humain vous
n'êtes pas ouvert vous n'êtes pas
charitable
vous n'êtes pas attendu vers les autres
vous n'écoutez pas mais j'en ai assez de
cela parce que ce ne sont que les
arguments de la fausse générosité
cette fausse générosité qui consiste ni
à se donner les moyens de bien
accueillir ce que nous avons décidé
d'accueillir cette fausse générosité qui
consiste de la même manière à ne pas
payer correctement à ce et sur ceux qui
sont chez nous ce débat immature c'est à
nous de le secouer c'est à nous de
refuser cette dictature des censeurs qui
veille à ce que le débat ne puisse pas
être objectivé et à ce qu'il ne puisse
pas y avoir un débat mature sur cette
question de l'immigration dans notre
pays cela suppose de dire et ne
l'oublions jamais quand on appartient à
la famille de la droite et du centre
cela suppose surtout de faire et nous
avons parfois péché pour l'un et
beaucoup pour l'autre
d'abord dire nous avons voulu avec
virginie guilhaume que l'intitulé de la
convention soit clair ce n'est pas une
convention sur l'immigration
c'est une convention sur comment réduire
l'immigration parce qu'il faut que les
choses soient nets ont fini dans notre
pays par se cacher derrière des mots qui
sont autant de slogans usées on dit
qu'il faut maîtriser les flux
migratoires on dit qu'il faut mieux
réguler on dit qu'il faut mieux
organiser non il faut dire les choses
très simplement
les républicains veulent une seule chose
sortir la france de l'immigration de
masse ni plus ni moins sortir la france
de l'immigration de masse je vais y
venir
qu'est ce que ça suppose précisément si
on veut tenir l'objectif d'abord ça
suppose une un changement complet dans
notre raisonnement
jusque là nous nous sommes trop
nous avons raisonné et guillaume eric
vous vous y êtes souvent heurtés dans un
cadre juridique constant consistant à
accepter par avance que tel aspect des
traités européens tel aspect de telles
conventions tel aspect de vieilles
négociations par exemple celle qui nous
lie avec l'algérie empêché par essence
de faire quoi que ce soit et du coup on
a juste mais on a juste à la marge et on
a nous mêmes
autant intégrer la capitulation du
politique qui d'ailleurs exaspère les
français ce que j'ai voulu est ce que
j'ai donné comme feuille de route aux
vingt parlementaires tous experts qui
ont travaillé pendant plus de deux mois
sur cette question c'est s'il faut aller
jusqu'à changer des traités modifier la
constitution sortir de tel ou tel ou tel
ou tel cadre juridique ont fait la
question c'est pas que notre politique
migratoire soit dictée par un cadre
juridique constants la question c'est de
se permettre tous les changements
juridiques qui sont nécessaires pour
atteindre l'objectif sortir de
l'immigration de masse
il n'y a pas de tabou il n'y a pas de
règles imposées la seule ligne est la
seule ligne de conduite c'est qu'est ce
que nous voulons pour la france et quel
est l'intérêt de notre pays ce qui vous
est proposé aujourd'hui est le fruit du
travail des parlementaires qui sont sans
doute aujourd'hui les meilleurs experts
de ces questions et qui appartiennent
tous à notre famille politique et je
suis fier de ce qu'ils ont fait parce
que ce sont tous des élus qui ont fait
l'effort de rentrer dans les détails du
maquis juridique qui est aujourd'hui ce
maquis juridique jurisprudentielle qui
aboutit à empêcher toute maîtrise de la
politique migratoire
je précise aussi on a eu cette échéance
tous ensemble que nous avons voulu sur
cette première convention nous
concentrer sur ce que la france doit
faire parce que trop souvent on se
défausse sur l'europe et ondimba
oui mais il faudrait conscience ça et ça
de l'europe on y viendra et vous savez à
quel point je veux changer des choses
dans le fonctionnement actuel de
l'europe qui est parfois devenu trop
public
mais là je veux d'abord qu'on se
concentre sur ce que la france peut
faire et il ya déjà beaucoup de choses
que nous nous pouvons faire tout de
suite pour mieux réguler l'immigration
le premier point c'est mettre un coup
d'arrêt aux entrées illégales nous avons
fini par perdre le bon sens
l'immigration illégale est illégal un
point c'est tout et il ne faut pas aller
au delà et si elle est illégale
cela signifie qu'elle doit être arrêté
comment comprendre par exemple que quand
nous agissons à nos frontières aux
frontières de l'europe avec les bateaux
qui viennent sur le continent européen
quand ils sont arrêtés ou est-ce qu'on
amène les migrants illégaux qui arrive
est ce qu'on les ramène sur la côte
libyenne
tunisienne ou est-ce qu'au contraire on
les accompagne pour les faire rentrer
sur le continent européen
comment ne pas être choqué par cette
folie qui consiste à ce que aujourd'hui
les forces de frontex les gardes-côtes
les opérations auxquelles les français
participent consiste juste à récupérer
les migrants illégaux et à les
accompagner
pour leur entrée sur le continent
européen mais cela on voit juste comme
signal que nous accueillons
l'immigration illégale
au lieu d'être très claires et de dire
non quand on vous arrête on vous
raccompagne de l'autre côté parce que si
précisément cette immigration est
illégal elle n'a rien à faire sur le
continent européen
c'est aussi simple que cela et ça c'est
le premier point que nous devons finir
la deuxième chose pourquoi y at il un
tel encouragement à l'immigration
irrégulière mais c'est parce que nous
laissons subsister l'espoir qu'il pourra
y avoir à l'arrivée une régularisation
ou un titre de séjour et les passeurs
vives de cela et les passeurs vivent de
cette instrumentalisation des espoirs
que par nos faiblesses nous laissons
alimenter l'australie a adopté une toute
autre conduite qui est très simple si
vous mettez un pied en australie sans y
avoir été autorisé
vous ne pourrez jamais obtenir de
régularisation ou de titres de séjour je
demande que nous brision une bonne fois
pour toutes les filières de
l'immigration irrégulière en adoptant
une règle simple consistant à dire que
si un étranger en dehors du droit
d'asile est entré de façon irrégulière
en france
il ne pourra jamais avoir accès à une
régularisation ou un titre de séjour
jamais ce qui suppose d'inscrire dans
nos textes juridiques le fait que quand
on vient de façon irrégulière en france
quand on a enfreint nos règles quand on
est venu de façon illégale
c'est une interdiction à vie d'accéder
un titre de séjour et à la possibilité
de séjourner régulièrement sur le
territoire français parce qu'aujourd'hui
ce que nous faisons c'est une prime à
l'illégalité et à l'irrégularité
il faut casser la mécanique de
l'immigration illégale
la deuxième chose c'est qu'il faut
ensuite que la france puisse faire à
nouveau respecter ces règles
sur son territoire le ministre de
l'intérieur lui-même a reconnu qu'il y
avait aujourd'hui 300 mille clandestins
sur le territoire français quand des
gens font des demandes d'asile et qu'on
constate qu'ils n'ont pas le droit à
l'asile et au statut de réfugié dans
combien de pourcentage des cas seront
ils reconduits à la frontière
4 % ça veut dire que pour toutes ces
personnes sur lesquelles la justice a
tranché et a très clairement dit ils
n'ont pas le droit de rester en france
dans 96% des cas la république décide de
fermer les yeux et juste de ne pas faire
appliquer les règles et la loi qui est
la nôtre mais comment peut-on ensuite
s'étonner qu'il n'y ait plus aucun sens
de l'autorité républicaine et du respect
des règles de droit
c'est pour cela que nous avons voulu
inscrire une règle très simple un
quinquennat pour en sortir et pour
organiser l'expulsion des trois cent
mille clandestins qui sont sur le
territoire français cela suppose de
revoir totalement notre politique d aide
au développement
et là encore j'aime juste qu'on ouvre
les yeux et qu'on regarde calmement mais
lucidement ce qui se passe nous
attribuons 350 millions d'euros des de
développement au mali
eh bien le mali a glorieusement accepter
le retour de 13 sans papiers 13 sans
papiers sur son territoire en 2017 et
tous les autres il refuse de donner des
récépissés permettant d'organiser la
reconduite à la frontière de maliens qui
sont en situation irrégulière en france
nous attribuons 180 millions d'euros d'
aide au développement à la tunisie
françois noël a parfaitement montré la
tunisie a accepté de reprendre cette
année
même pas une centaine de tunisiens dans
le cadre des procédures de reconduite à
la frontière
l'allemagne est beaucoup plus exigeante
l'allemagne est beaucoup plus claire
l'allemagne elle organise de façon
beaucoup plus systématique des vols de
reconduite à la frontière avec des
charters groupe et qui permettent de
systématiser et bien je demande une
chose qui est tout simple
ces conditionnalités total de l'aide au
développement au fait que les pays
acceptent de donner mais récipissé pour
reprendre leurs ressortissants qui n'ont
rien à faire sur le territoire français
et s'ils ne le veulent pas il n'ya plus
qu'à des développements et nous devons
aussi guillaume comme tu l'a rappelé
expulser les étrangers délinquants
cela suppose de restaurer intégralement
la double peine
restaurer intégralement la double peine
comment garder sur notre territoire des
étrangers qui comme premier signal de
respect du pays qui leur tend les mains
et qui a accepté de les accueillir
commence par enfreindre les règles de
notre pays et commettre des délits
il ya aujourd'hui dans les prisons
françaises
un prisonnier sur cinq qui est de
nationalité étrangère il est temps de
dire clairement que quand on commet un
délit en france on ne reste pas en
france et que si on veut rester en
france on respecte les règles qui sont
les nôtres et qui permettent juste de
vivre ensemble je vais aller au delà
j'ai eu hier une rencontre qui m'a
beaucoup marqué avec une personne qui
voulait venir me voir j'ai eu le courage
de témoigner contre tariq ramadan et qui
témoignaient de la diffusion progressive
du discours de haine de la france qui
est diffusée notamment par les réseaux
salafistes nous ne faisons rien
nous restons passifs ces gens-là
professe un discours de haine de notre
pays et de racisme contre la france il
en doctrine les esprits tous les jours
et notamment les étrangers qui sont sur
notre territoire y contribuer ceux qui
sont radicalisés et ceux qui sont fichés
et suivi par le ministère de l'intérieur
et nous n'en tirons aucune conséquence
le président de la république se
glorifie qu'il y ait eu une vingtaine
d'étrangers radicaliser reconduits à la
frontière en 2017
il y en a trois mille qui sont suivis
dans notre pays pour radicalisation et
professions de haine contre la france
les républicains font cette proposition
très simple de créer un délit
d'incitation à la haine contre la france
et quand on professe la haine contre la
france et qu'on est un étranger on ne
reste pas sur le territoire français on
est reconduit à la frontière
c'est la troisième proposition qu'il
faisait
enfin la france doit pouvoir décider si
elle accepte et qui n acceptent pas sur
son territoire même le canada pays
pourtant marqué par une politique que je
ne souhaite pas à la france même le
canada est capable lui d'avoir une
politique migratoire qui le pi lui
permet de décider qui est accepté de
quel pays sur quelle profession
nous notre politique est devenue une
politique totalement aveugle dans
laquelle nous ne décidons plus de rien
plus qui nous voulons plus dans quel
métier plus dans quelle origine et
surtout plus combien les capacités
d'intégration ont une limite
il faut donc que nous puissions voter
eric des plafonds d'immigration
annuellement qui seront adoptées par le
parlement et qui permettront de
reprendre la main sur le nombre de
titres de séjour qui seront délivrés
nous pouvons intégrer des individus mais
nous ne pouvons pas assimiler des
peuples l'autriche le fait le canada le
fait l'allemagne s'apprête à adopter des
règles en la matière nous sommes le seul
pays européen à poursuivre dans notre
aveuglement
actuellement nous devons de ce point de
vue aller jusqu'à poser la question de
l'immigration familiale
aujourd'hui je parle sous votre contrôle
elle est devenue une des premières
causes d'immigration en france avec 90
mille titres de séjour sur les 262 me
trop souvent on en reste à la seule
question du regroupement familial qui
est une façon de voir que la face
émergée de l'iceberg pas anecdotique
contrairement à ce que j'entends parfois
c'est quand même 23 mille titres de
séjour c'est pas anecdotique mais ça
n'est pas l'essentiel c'est bien
l'ensemble de l'immigration familiale
que je veux voir traiter celles qui
fonctionnent par les mariages plus ou
moins blanc plus ou moins fait fort
c'est celle qui fonctionne par le
regroupement fait
y'a pas seulement ceux des étrangers
mais celle aussi de français qui font
venir ensuite une partie de la famille
dans le cadre d'un mariage qui a été
fait c'est cette immigration familiale
globalement que nous devons réguler il
ne peut pas y avoir de droit automatique
pour les immigrés à faire venir trois à
quatre membres de leur famille en
moyenne dès que l'un d'entre eux est
arrivée sur le territoire français nos
règles là dessus reste beaucoup trop
permissifs si vous voulez faire venir
des membres de votre famille il faut que
vous puissiez les loger si vous voulez
faire venir des membres de votre famille
il faut que vous puissiez les nourrir et
que nous ne dépendions pas des
prestations familiales les plafonds qui
aujourd'hui sont posées sont totalement
anecdotique nous proposons deux doublés
aussi bien les critères de ressources
que les conditions de logement et je me
permets d'ajouter autre chose il faut
avoir un minimum séjourner en france il
faut avoir montré sa capacité à
respecter nos règles avant de pouvoir
prétendre à au regroupement familial et
à l'immigration familiale
je demande donc avant trois ans ils
soient strictement interdit de pouvoir
accéder aux règles du regroupement
familial et que nous arrêtions ce
système dans lequel portes et fenêtres
restent ouvertes et où nous ne
contrôlons plus rien je voudrais enfin
pour finir poser la question de la
nationalité et c'est une profonde
différence entre nous et même les
membres les plus lucides de ce qui est
une majorité malheureusement très
défaillante sur ces sujets je pense par
exemple à quelqu'un comme manuel valls
je respecte manuel valls parce que à la
différence du président de la république
il un discours qui éclaire sur la
laïcité et sur le multiculturalisme mais
j'ai une profonde différence avec lui
pour manuel valls la nationalité est une
étape dans un parcours d'intégration
pour nous la france ne doit donner la
nationalité que la main tremblante en
étant sûr que celui ou celle auquel on
donne la nationalité est parti
hautement intégrée et comprend
parfaitement les règles et le
fonctionnement de la république
française
cela suppose oui de revenir sur le droit
du sol et je voulais dit il n'y a pas de
sujet tabou
mansour est ici et peut témoigner de la
façon dont aujourd'hui le droit du sol
est totalement détournées à mayotte avec
des clandestins qui arrivent à mayotte
en ayant juste l'espoir que si leurs
enfants naissent à mayotte sur le sol
français
ils auront droit automatiquement ensuite
à la nationalité française
avec la possibilité ensuite de faire
venir toute la famille sur le sol
français
est-ce que c'est cela le droit du sol
est-ce que c'est cela la conception de
l'immigration que nous nous devons
défendre le droit du sol ça n'est pas
cela quand il a été conçu à la fin du 2
du 19e siècle
il n'était pas fait pour cela
aujourd'hui il a été totalement
détournés et sortis de sa vocation
initiale et nous ne pouvons plus
continuer comme cela
je demande donc que l'on revienne sur le
droit du sol et que l'on fixe une règle
simple
en nous inspirant de l'allemagne si les
parents sont en situation irrégulière
sur le sol français il n'ya pas d'accès
et de droit du sol une situation simple
si les parents sont en situation
irrégulière on ne peut pas prétendre
accéder à la nationalisation par le
biais du droit du sol
et enfin on ne peut pas devenir français
par hasard on ne peut pas devenir
français si on n'a pas parfaitement
intégrer l'exigence et la beauté de ce
que représente le fait de faire partie
de la nation française on ne peut pas
devenir français si on n'a pas un casier
judiciaire qui est vierge
on ne peut pas devenir français sans
être majeur parce que je ne veux plus
qu'on devienne français par accident
mais tu as rêvé d'assister à des
cérémonies de distribution des diplômes
de la nationalité française est de
constater parfois malgré tous les
contrôles
tous les examens toutes les mesures qui
sont fait que bien souvent les gens qui
venaient chercher leur diplôme ne
comprenait pas très bien ce que je leur
disais et les propos que je le retenais
parce que la maîtrise du français
n'était que trop incertaine je vais
aller à quelque chose qui me tient
beaucoup plus à coeur
je n'attends pas seulement d'un étranger
auquel on donne la nationalité française
qu'ils parlent le français
je n'attends pas seulement de lui qu'il
connaisse les rudiments de l'histoire de
france
j'attends de lui qu'il adhère totalement
aux valeurs de la république
qu'est ce que ça veut dire ça veut dire
que je ne donne pas la nationalité
française à quelqu'un qui considère que
la charia est supérieure aux lois de la
république ça veut dire que je ne donne
pas la nationalité française à quelqu'un
qui n'a pas parfaitement intégré que
chez nous l'égalité de l'homme et de la
femme n'était pas négociable
ça veut dire que je ne donne pas la
nationalité française à quelqu'un qui
considère qu'il peut imposer le port du
voile à sa femme ou à sa soeur ça veut
dire que au moment où nous donnons la
nationalité française
il faut qu'il y ait une prestation de
serment et de respect et d'adhésion aux
valeurs de la république française pour
forcer tout le monde à sortir de
l'hypocrisie
non la france ne peut pas accepter
où et n'importe quoi ce ne sera pas
facile mais rien n'est facile dans ce
parcours de reconstruction et cela
suppose aussi comme david gold arte l'a
très bien montré
c'est qu'il faut que nous sortions d'un
discours qui a été confisqué par
certains et que nous redonnions tout
simplement la parole aux français
je me souviens d'un très beau débat qui
avait eu lieu entre georges clemenceau
et jules ferry sur la colonisation et
georges clemenceau avait interpellé
c'est une époque où un des discours
politiques avaient de la hauteur et du
souffle avait un père pauli ferry en lui
disant vous n'avez même pas pris la
peine de consulter le pays
on lui a systématiquement cacher la
vérité et on essaye maintenant
d'accommoder les faits à une doctrine
inventé pour la cause clemenceau avait
raison dans une démocratie
vous ne pouvez pas l'emporter sur la
durée en tournant le dos au peuple en
l'empêchant d'arbitré et de décider et
trans pays que le nôtre qui brandit la
démocratie participative pour consulter
par exemple les parisiens sur le futur
itinéraire du marathon à paris étrange
pays que le nôtre que celui dans lequel
un président de la république dit que il
n'exclut pas de recourir au référendum
notamment pour consulter les français
sur une question aussi stratégique que
l'utilisation ou non de la
proportionnelle et qui dans le même
temps depuis 30 ans a systématiquement
refusé de consulter les français à un
moment sur une question qui à ce
point-là transformer le visage de notre
pays celui de l'immigration
nous devrions pourtant prendre garde
parce que comme monsieur godard l'a très
bien montré lors du vote du bric site
les britanniques eux se sont saisis de
la possibilité qu'il aurait est enfin
donnée de s'exprimer pour dire
clairement qu'il ne voulait pas de cette
ouverture
nous devrions prendre garde parce que
comme cela a très bien été montré notre
pays cherchent à tout prix à camoufler
le plus possible tous les sondages qui
porte sur cette question en août est sur
tous les sujets dans tous les sens ce
matin midi et soir
regardez la faiblesse du nombre de
sondages qui sont faits sur les
questions migratoires et je verrai avec
beaucoup de plaisir
les français interrogés sur cette
question pour que l'on mesure ce qu'ils
veulent et ce qu'ils attendent vraiment
je considère que les français ont le
droit de choisir sur cette question
qu'ils ont droit de s'exprimer
c'est pour cette raison que je veux
qu'il puisse y avoir un référendum pour
que ce soit les français qui décide ce
n'est pas aux pacers ce n'est pas aux
juges de décider qui entre en france
c'est aux français de le décider c'est
leur pays
ce sont leurs frontières c'est notre
peuple
ce sera leur choix je veux que les
français puissent s'exprimer une bonne
fois pour toutes à travers un référendum
sur ce qu'il souhaite
en termes d'immigration
alors nous avons une grande
responsabilité parce que ce sujet là ne
souffre pas les ambiguïtés
parce qu'on le voit très bien avec la
façon dont le débat a commencé à
l'assemblée nationale le discours d'
emmanuel macron et frapper de toutes les
ambiguïtés sur cette question et il ne
fait preuve d'aucune fermeté sur ce
sujet à peine quelques minutes en quatre
heures d'interviews la semaine dernière
consacrée à cette question il ne faut
rien en attendre là dessus et il faut
juste que nous soyons clairs ce
président de la république sur ce sujet
n'a pas la fermeté qui s'imposent
de l'autre côté le discours du front
national conduit dans l'impasse
parce que systématiquement il permet à
tous les censeurs du débat de fermer
toute forme de discussion en brandissant
les étendards du politiquement correct
c'est la responsabilité des républicains
de porter ce débat c'est la
responsabilité des républicains de le
porter avec détermination et esprit de
responsabilité et de quoi aurions nous
peur je relisais hier les propositions
qui avaient été faites par des
personnalités que j'admire beaucoup de
notre famille politique au début des
années 90 il s'appelait jacques chirac
il s'appelait valéry giscard d'estaing
il s'appelait alain juppé et à l'époque
la droite n'avait pas encore démissionné
et il portait un discours qui était
clair sur les migrations disant qu'il
fallait que nous puissions sortir des
règles qui avait abouti à une
immigration incontrôlée dans notre pays
les années 90 ont été terribles pour la
droite parce qu'elles ont
progressivement conduit à cette
abdication et à cette capitulation qui
nous a été et avec raison si souvent
reproché en partie
en partie c'est vrai pas seulement je
pense que nous y avons nous mêmes
contribué mais bien sûr vous avez raison
et avec parfois des attitudes que je
vois se reproduire mitterrand est celui
qui a utilisé la proportionnelle
mitterrand est celui qui a utilisé le
front national pour étouffer la voix de
la droite et je vois beaucoup
d'analogies dans parfois l'attitude
actuelle qui est portée consistant à
essayer de faire en sorte que entre en
marche et les extrêmes
il n'y ait plus rien et bien c'est à
nous de défier cela vous connaissez ma
conviction c'est un chemin exigeant
c'est un chemin qui suppose de ne pas
chercher à plaire à ceux qui décerne les
bons points ou les mauvais points dans
notre pays c'est un chemin qui consiste
à s'imposer toujours ce devoir de
lucidité voire faire preuve de bon sens
dire et ne jamais oublier qu'à l'arrivée
la seule chose sur laquelle nous serons
attendus
c'est de faire j'aime ce que disait
charles péguy rien n'est meurtrier comme
la lâcheté rien n'est humains comme la
fermeté les français attendent une
politique ferme en matière d'immigration
c'est le devoir des républicains de le
porter et croyez moi ma détermination
sera totale merci à vous
[Applaudissements]